[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous n'imaginez pas à quel point je
trouve cette situation invivable tout un
jeu tout d'abord tout d'abord je suis
prisonnier de ce cercle rouge échoué sur
cette estrade comme une fatale goutte de
sang qui tombent du plafond et ensuite
je suis prisonnier de la présentation
convient tout de faire de moi enfin je
veux dire m mais comment m'en sortir à
quel naufrage sont mous et tous s'y fie
ça va être un désastre
la première chose c'est que c'est
impossible de mettre la main sur un
début il n'existe pas deux premières
phrases valable je veux dire que à
chaque fois que j'essaye de remonter le
cours de ma pensée je retrouve un début
qui en contrarier un autre les
influences de ma bête et tous les
fleuves qui pas pour mon esprit sont en
feu impossible de savoir quelle est la
première phrase il n'y a pas de première
phase donc le mieux ce serait même de
commencer par un fin c'est à dire que je
m'en aille
nous économiserions ainsi 17 minutes de
désordre et moi 16 minutes de génie
étant donné que je sais qu'il a toujours
une minute de silence à peu près dans ma
parole parce que d'écouter quand même et
quand je dis que la situation est
ridicule c'est pas qu'elle est ridicule
puisque vous avez juste vraiment je suis
très heureux d'être là lumière dans la
lumière mais ce que je vais faire ce
guêpier qu'attendez-vous des mots je
veux dire qu attendons des mots moi j'ai
l'impression à chaque fois que je parle
que les mots vivent sous une banquise
qui craque et des ptt les noms de dieu
et que le sens et que le sens des robes
à chax moi je ne sais pas jouer le jeu
je ne sais pas c'est impensable la
conquête du palm ont un tel sujet gros
test
la conquête la donne non non non non non
j'espère que vous n'espérez pas de moi
une seule seconde que que que je
m'habille nice à répondre à une question
pareille non pas que la question soit
ridicule c'est que moi je plus je
m'éloigne du cercle plus j'ai
l'impression d'être au centre de 2,2 du
sujet autrement dit je vais parler de
tout sauf de la conquête et à et à la
fin d'habitude je fais ça en deux heures
et demie et a dit je mettrai la main sur
une frappe frappe et vous repartiez
avec un legs subi je l'espère c'est
aussi un art des rites et enfin je veux
dire vous comprenez ce que je sais c'est
un marc hardy rites et c'est cette année
dès l'été c'est un art vérité c'est un
art vérité c'est un art d'hériter du but
du costume que je porte là vous voyez
alors je je je je je je porte le costume
de mon grand père qui s'est marié en
1944 dans plus autour de mes apparitions
publiques
je ne m'habille autrement à vrai dire au
départ vous savez quand vous êtes
musicien enfin quand vous êtes un homme
de scène la première question qui se
pose c'est bon il faut s'habiller bien
bon après je dit bon écoute mon
s'appuyer bien c'est quand même ses
succès c'est quand même peu de choses de
mettre beaucoup d'argent dans les
vêtements alors je me suis dit bon il
faut juste t'habiller apitoie simplement
comme tu l'as blick occupe quand tu
traverses la main je me présenter devant
les assemblées tout tout tout tout tout
tout tout tout tout tout
il y a c'est marrant parce que mon
grand-père se marie en 1944 sous les
bombardements et et et me voilà portant
ce costume lorsque je porte ce costume
je n'ai pas du tout le sentiment de
porter le poids du passé
j'ai au contraire le le comment tirage
au contraire la soif d'offrir du futur à
ce truc je porte avec moi alors plus la
chance que j'ai c'est qu'il est
évidemment trop court comme vous le
voyez génère ridicule le ridicule étant
à mon avis à mon avis à mon humble avis
le ridicule étant vraiment le il faut
commencer par le ridicule
il ya vraiment une phrase complètement
grotesque que vous connaissez tous qui
dit que le ridicule ne tue pas mais non
mais le ridicule ne tue pas c'est pas
que le ridicule ne tue pas c'est que le
ridicule fait exister j'entends parler
depuis tout à l'heure de philosophes et
fermé par renault est un des premiers
films de l'histoire diogène à poil dans
un tonneau offre vraiment suffocant dans
sa merde et son urine enfin vous
comprenez ce que je veux dire le risque
n'existe que par le ridicule et démarre
qu'à nantes vous fait rire comme moi
j'essaye de vous faire rire
non je n'essaye pas
mais dès lors que vous trouvez un homme
ridicule bah en fait lui se met au défi
de dire une parole sérieuse encore plus
haute que la vie qu'ils portent
ainsi donc ce costume se trouve
précisément au centre de mon existence
autrement dit il ya autant de passer
derrière lui que d'avenir de m'ennuie
l'horizon est une drôle de chose à
chaque fois que j'avance et que je fixe
l'horizon je me pose la question
suivante je me dis mais mes aînés mais
est ce que est ce que l'horizon recul ou
est-ce que l'horizon avance avec moi je
suis j'ai été renvoyé du conservatoire
j'ai fait mes études au conservatoire et
j'ai été renvoyé je crois que j'étais
savez un insoluble dans l'institution
mais je n'ai vraiment ce qui me fait
plus rien du tout parce que maintenant
j'ai compris à quel point toute
institution est instrument de
dévitalisation donc alors j'étais on m'a
renvoyé parce qu'évidemment j'ai
beaucoup plus de talent que mon
professeur qui est devenu un homme
vraiment absolument sublime de
médiocrité avec beaucoup de talent mais
le médiocre malgré tout et on rejoint là
à cette heure précise de la fin de mon
adolescence libre
mais libre vous savez moi je vais vous
dire un truc très important avez vous
remarqué que les lélés les avez vous
remarqué aucune raison de crier à aa
avez vous avez vous remarqué que les les
les bons élèves comme les mauvais
professeurs font de tous la même
remarque qu'il vous dise la chose
suivante et vous disent l'importance de
l'apprentissage c'est d'abord de définir
le cadre est ensuite de se sentir et
d'essayer de trouver la liberté au sein
du cadre alors on vous apprend par et il
a pensé avec une introduction une thèse
antithèse synthèse d'une conclusion que
ces terrains non non non mais non nommés
non non mais donc non non non non non
non non non
ouais mais c'est complètement idiot mais
non le préalable c'est la liberté
le préalable c'est la liberté le
préalable c'est pas le cadre c'est une
connaissance ou ça mais non le préalable
c'est d'abord la liberté oui lui la
liberté vous oblige ensuite à définir
vous même votre propre regard
et ça c'est encore plus sublime je vous
faire la démonstration éloquente je
l'espère musicale le mieux que je
pourrai de te de mon apprentissage en
tant que clarinettiste au départ quand
son entrée au conservatoire on vous
apprend la technique classique dont vous
jouez par mozart mozart le pauvre mozart
le pauvre mozart le pauvre mozart je me
méfie toujours des mélomanes vous savez
je comprends pas mozart septembre 7
mozart c'est tanguy
kikititi qui meurt dans la misère la
plus totale contexte dans une fosse
commune et de siècle après on fait du
chocolat avait jugé vraiment mais mais
comment ne pas en vouloir
jusqu'à la fin des temps mais nos mains
véritablement je trouve ça terrible je
me suis dit même mois mais héliose
plutôt datant de mourir fabrique du
chocolat hélios fin déjà tu feras
l'expérience métaphysique de la
postérité
parce que nous sommes tous des sit in et
nous sommes deux j'ai dit nous sommes
tous décidés à finir en boîte de
chocolats ou dans une cravate regarder
arthur à mort pour moi je vois que les
gens portent une cravate à turin je me
dis pas je me dit qu'il m'aime bien et
mieux je vais vous jouer mozart
je vais vu jouer mozart et vous allez
voir vous allez entendre a remarqué voir
entendre n'est ce pas à jouer mozart
par exemple certains connaissent
peut-être le le concerto pour clarinette
de mozart joue une partie du mouvement
lance pas
[Musique]
je m'attendais à des applaudissements
mais en même temps je n'exige pas
complètement
donc nous demandons surtout surtout
surtout pas un seul fait il n'y a rien
de pire que le cap comme ça claque
soit tout le monde soit personne enfin
en fait à travailler comme ça j'avais
l'impression de rester à la surface du
son donc il avant je me suis dirigé vers
une musique beaucoup plus mais un autre
chose par exemple au jazz essayons
[Musique]
il me revient à l'esprit un scandale
bien involontaire comme un certain
nombre de scandales que j'ai déjà créé
alors il m'est arrivé de vives et des
ânes mais il m'est rarement arrivé de
vider des scènes et un jour que je
donnais un concert de la musique de
django reinhardt avec des musiciens ce
qu'on appelle le jazz manouche et il y
avait le guitariste soliste qui devait
prendre le chorus juste après moi
n'est ce pas et puis alors la fin de mon
corps et je me retourne comme ça
t'aidera et et il était parti
et alors évidemment j'ai pas compris
mais je les retrouvais entre les deux
sets
n'est ce pas à l'extérieur mais mais
mais mais mais mais mais qu'est ce qui
t'arrive des balles afin que le malade
ans et aristide quelque chose et tu as
atteint d'une maladie
je n'aurais pas subodorer bien fait et
dit non helios qu'elle joue sans
nullement pas du tout à la manière de
surcroît reinhardt le style de django
reinhardt c'est pas toi tu n'y arrives
pas tu vois la manière telle clause est
de ses pâtures morena et là je dis mon
gros qu'elle serait pas le dernier des
abrutis
car django reinhardt ne jouais pas à la
manière que django reinhardt giorgo
reinhardt temporelle pour bon temps
écouter ni ces dames suis-je obligé de
vous expliquer la chose suivante le
style le style armes a dit surtout
dépasse pas le rond rouge le style
le style ne soit pas de vos miles davis
m'a vu jouer qu'on publie t pourquoi pas
moi le style de django reinhardt le
style d'une manière générale mais pas
l'occupation d'un territoire déjà
conquis ses parages où elle le style le
site situe précisément c'est une le
style précisément c'est une conquête non
mais je m'en venais soufflerait presque
et puis m'est arrivé de couper ma
clarinette en deux vous savez
il suffit de briser en deux une
certitude pour qu'arras continent c'est
cool
voyez
dès qu'on tente la poésie il y en a deux
trois qui pousse et laissez moi vous
présenter cet instrument que j'ai appelé
le suprême car on ne rigolait pas
suprême cayron çà çà çà çà çà vient en
droite ligne d'arthur rimbaud voyelles
aux suprêmes clairon plein dé ce
thriller étrange silence traversée des
monts et des anges au l'oméga rayon viol
et de ses yeux
[Musique]
ouais
bah
si j'en crois le le chronomètre
il me reste une minute et quinze
secondes pour vous donner à voir
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
n'abusez pas trop surmontant six là on
se sait c'est c c'est une des fins
possibles au revoir
[Applaudissements]